>>> RUSSIA CONTINUES ITS
VICIOUS ATTACKS ON UKRAINE, 3
MILLION REFUGEES HE LEFT THEIR
HOMES.
WE HAVE A TRULY REMARKABLE STORY
OF IMMEASURABLE KINDNESS REPAID
OVER GENERATIONS TO TWO
UKRAINIAN REFUGEES.
DURING WORLD WAR II, SHE
SHELTERED AND SAVED THE LIFE OF
A UKRAINIAN JEW.
HER GRANDDAUGHTER IS RETURNING
THE FAVOR.
SHE IS HELPING TO BRING MARIA'S
FAMILY FROM UKRAINE TO ISRAEL.
JOINING ME NOW IS SHARON BASS.
SHARON, THIS STORY IS AMAZING.
AND I THINK ABOUT WATCHING YOU.
I SEE YOU.
YOU ARE HERE BECAUSE YOUR
GRANDMOTHER SURVIVED BECAUSE OF
SOMEONE ELSE'S GRANDMOTHER.
THE ROLES ARE REALLY REVERSED
HERE.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR GRANDMOTHER'S
SURVIVAL OF WORLD WAR II FIRST.
>> OKAY.
SO THE START OF MY GRANDMOTHER
AND MY WHOLE FAMILY GOES BACK 80
YEARS AGO TO WORLD WAR II WHEN
MY GRANDMOTHER WAS THE SOLE
SURVIVOR OF HER FAMILY.
THE REST OF THE FAMILY WAS
SLAUGHTERED AND PUT IN MASS
GRAVES BY THE NAZIS.
SHE FOUND HERSELF WANDERING THE
FOREST OF UKRAINE.
UNTIL ONE YEAR LATER, THIS
RIGHTEOUS FAMILY FOUND HER IN
THE FOREST AND GAVE HER A HOME,
SHELTER, AND TREATED HER LIKE
THEIR OWN DAUGHTER.
BY DOING THAT, THE WHOLE FAMILY,
I AM IN DEBTED TO THEM FOREVER.
AND I FEEL, LIKE YOU SAID, THE
REASON I'M HERE ALIVE AND I HAVE
FAMILY, THREE SONS, YOU KNOW, IS
BECAUSE OF THEM.
IT WAS MY MORAL OBLIGATION TO
ASSIST THEM AND GET THEM OUT OF
THE WAR ZONE.
>> SO MARIA, WHO IS THE WOMAN
WHO SAVED YOUR GRANDMOTHER, THIS
IS HER GRANDDAUGHTER LESSIA AND
HER GREAT NIECE ALONA.
YOU HAVE BEEN IN TOUCH WITH THEM
FOR DECADES.
I WONDER WHAT YOU WERE THINKING
WHEN YOU SAW RUSSIA WAS INVADING
UKRAINE AND JUST HOW INCREDIBLY
WORRIED YOU WERE FOR THEM.
>> YEAH.
WE WERE VERY WORRIED.
WE COULDN'T IMAGINE THE
SITUATION WOULD GO TO A WAR.
WE TALKED AND SENSED THE FEEL.
THEY WANTED TO COME AND BE SAFE.
IT WASN'T A QUESTION FOR ME.
IT WAS OBVIOUS FOR ME TO BRING
THEM HERE TO BE SAFE.
ALTHOUGH, YOU KNOW, THEIR GUILT
FEELINGS FOR LEAVING THEIR
FAMILY BACK THERE.
BUT THAT FAMILY WANTED THEM TO
BE SAFE.
SO IT'S HOME FOR THEM.
WE'RE VERY HAPPY.
AND OUR THOUGHTS ARE WITH THE
PEOPLE BACK IN UKRAINE.
>> SHARON, TELL US ABOUT THIS.
THERE ARE STILL STRUGGLES.
I KNOW THEY HAVE HAD PROBLEMS
WITH VISAS AND THAT YOU WANT
ISRAEL TO DO MORE TO HELP PEOPLE
LIKE YOUR REALLY ADOPTED FAMILY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK NEEDS TO
HAPPEN?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE SUBMITTED
A REQUEST THAT THEY COULD COME
HERE AND A WEEK AND A HALF AGO.
AND THE IMMEDIATE ANSWER WAS NO.
AND I COULDN'T ACCEPT IT.
BECAUSE MY GRANDMOTHER AND
GRANDFATHER WERE SHELTERED FOR
AS LONG AS THEY NEEDED BACK THEN
WHEN IT WAS REALLY HORRIFIC.
THEY WOULD KILL EVERYONE.
I INVOLVED THE MEDIA.
FROM THEN ON IT WAS THE INTEREST
THAT PEOPLE FOUND IN THIS STORY
WAS AMAZING.
SO THE FORMER HEAD OF THE JEWISH
AGENCY AND FOREIGN MINISTRY IT
WAS CANCELED.
THE REASON THEY DIDN'T GET,
LIKE, YOU KNOW, IMMEDIATE
ACCEPTANCE IS THAT THERE IS A
GUEST VISA AMONG THE NATIONS FOR
FIVE YEARS VISA TO COME HERE AND
WORK.
SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S -- IF I CAN
COMPARE IT, MY GRANDMOTHER, SHE
DIDN'T GET A TIME LIMIT ON HER
STAY OVER THERE WHEN IT WAS
REALLY TERRIBLE AND, YOU KNOW,
ALL HER FAMILY WAS MURDERED.
AND NOW WE SHOULD NOT DO THAT
EITHER.
>> WELL, SHARON, SHE DIDN'T HAVE
A TIME LIMIT, AS YOU SAID.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU, THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
IT IS AMAZING TO HEAR THIS STORY
OF KINDNESS AND BRAVERY REPAID
GENERATIONS LATER.
SHARON, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BEST OF LUCK TO YOUR ADOPTED
FAMILY.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY IN EVIL --
WE HAVE A SAYING.
YOU SHOULD TREAT YOUR NEIGHBOR